maybe your army comes and maybe it's too
much for us but it's all on you if we
can't protect the Earth you can be damn
well sure we'll avenge it alright
everybody so we have a leak from someone
who claims to have seen the Avengers 4
trailer as always there is no way to
tell if this leak is legitimate or not
but for the sake that it could be real
I'm gonna talk about it it's also kind
of my favourite version of all of these
trailer descriptions that have been
leaked because of the words at the end
and because of what this leaks as the
title is so I'm gonna read it word for
word and after I'll break it down and
talk about it also I'm still giving away
a infinity war art of the movie art book
along with an infinity war Deadpool 2 or
ant-man and the wasp blu-ray and some
special edition posters if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so this was leaked yesterday
and here's the description a man in a
hoodie and downpour of rain walks toward
a house and knocks on the door facing
away from the camera he knocks and Bruce
Banner answers the door and is surprised
to see Tony Stark who he says he hasn't
seen in years
both men looked considerably older and
as Tony sips on something hot in Bruce's
house Tony is talking and shivering kind
of fast but he's talking about missing
the signs and what they could have done
to stop Thanos before it was too late
and as he's saying this long dramatic
speech there are flashbacks to previous
MCU movies and Bruce finally tells Tony
to calm down because you can't change
the past Tony looks up for the first
time since he sat down and says what if
you could Bruce looks at him half
stunned and Tony starts to smirk then
they cut to a black screen and an
Avengers title card but the R in the S
fade away like the snap and the logo
changes from dark to shiny and gets
really bright and flashes and we have
the new title card avenge them ok so I'm
not sure if it was just me or if anybody
else got chills when Tony says what if
you could or with the new title card
avenge them but I did whether or not
this is real or not
but keep in mind that if the trailer
really is coming this
that means we only have nine days left
in the month that means that if the
trailer is done it's probably been
shipped out to theaters by now which
means that leaks like this could arise
if it's a teaser trailer then this
description sort of fits that it doesn't
give away too much but it does tell us
that time travel will be involved and it
does give us the title and at this point
I don't think we're going to get the
title until we get the trailer but the
title avenge them I like it it is sort
of a scary title because this implies
that the Avengers are dead now I know
that the Russo brothers said that
Avengers Forever was the closest that
anyone's guess to what the title was but
we really don't know what it is maybe
forever has something to do with the
Avengers that died in Avengers 4 are
going to be dead forever and that the
Avengers that are remaining need to
avenge them and this hasn't been said to
my knowledge in any of the Avengers
movies but we have gotten very close to
it in the very first Avengers movie
because we can't protect the Earth you
can be damn well sure we'll avenge it to
me this title would sort of tie in the
very beginning of the Avengers when they
came together to the end of the Avengers
that we currently know since this is
supposed to wrap up the story arcs from
the first ten years so maybe this could
be the title and maybe this description
leaked is real it did come from the same
source that was right about the last
Jedi prediction so you never really know
but as always take it with a grain of
salt I told you all that I would always
report these leaks so let me know what
you think about it does this link
description fit a good first teaser
trailer for Avengers 4 and what do you
think about the title avenge them let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always I appreciate you all watching
wolf wolf
[Music]